tonight on the new reality
they're not where you think they are and
they're moving around you know much
faster than we can
actually detect them a variant with a
vengeance
we need to do more the virus is fast in
learning how to
treat our system is that enough to get a
sense of how prevalent the variants are
this is the one million dollar question
[Music]
i remember being 13 14 years old and
seeing black people on stage that made
me believe
that it was possible actors and brothers
shamir anderson and stefan james are two
of canada's brightest talents
shamir and i were seeing much of the
same problems not only in canada but all
over the world there's not enough
places to celebrate black excellence
hello and welcome to the new reality i'm
donna friesen
the world didn't know what to expect
from the novel coronavirus when it first
emerged more than a year ago
now we don't know what to expect from
its much more transmissible variants
the virus is constantly a step ahead the
variants which have rapidly evolved are
evidence of that
we do have vaccines now which is a
remarkable achievement
but the variants are infecting people
faster than the vaccines can be rolled
out
and there's evidence emerging people who
have recovered from covid19
can possibly be reinfected with the
variants which means
though case numbers are on the decline
in canada right now
it could be the calm before the storm
even where the roads run out
the race is on here
deep in the amazon rainforest of brazil
these nurses are delivering precious
covid19 vaccine
bringing hope in a second deadly wave of
the pandemic
to a region still haunted by the first
[Music]
thank you thank you says this woman one
of the first to be vaccinated
her relief is real few places have been
hit as hard as the state of amazonas
a new highly contagious variant is
driving another massive surge in cases
here
there are alarming signs it could evade
the immunity of those who have already
recovered from cobig 19
and it's one of several variants of
concern that could change the course of
the pandemic
everywhere down river in the capital
city of manaus
no one thought the virus could strike
like this again
hospital corridors team with coveted
patients
too few beds not enough staff
relatives forced to find scarce oxygen
tanks
there are never enough one hospital ran
out entirely
patients began to suffocate and die
the leader rosha's mother-in-law was one
of them
there's no more oxygen in the entire
health unit she says
so many people are dying
hospitals are now turning patients away
sent home to be cared for
by family others left on their own
without oxygen they die where they lay
what defies belief is the intensity and
ferocious speed of the spread
a variant with a vengeance it was
thought the devastating first wave eight
months ago which is believed to have
infected
the majority of people here should have
produced herd immunity
yet this sudden surge in sickness is
even worse
and these mutations are spreading across
the globe
the discovery of a second major variable
the new variant of covet 19 that the
coronavirus is evolving
is not unexpected there are thousands
of variants of the virus out there in
the world so the question becomes what
makes
a particular variant a variant of
concern and what allowed them
to evolve so rapidly the first genetic
sequence of the novel coronavirus came
from a sample taken from a worker in the
seafood market in wuhan china
that seed has grown branching out into a
family tree
the more people the virus infects the
more it replicates
over time genetic changes occur creating
new
branches known as variants most variants
are of little concern but three have
emerged with advantages
allowing them to thrive and outrun
others
they were first detected in the uk south
africa and
brazil and what makes them extraordinary
are the number of mutations
they've acquired at once and
all three possess the n501y mutation
it affects the all-important spike
protein the key that
opens the way into healthy human cells
making these variants up to 50 percent
more
contagious
most patients have no idea how they got
but the virus
and that's a general trend back in
canada at toronto's humber river
hospital
covent cases in the icu are slowly
receding
but dr jamie spiegelman is wary
some patients have really minimal or no
symptoms
and some patients are so sick that they
die within a couple of hours of coming
to hospital
no matter what we do for them he knows
the threat from variants
is looming it's way more transmissible
and contagious
which is concerning because we know the
original virus was very contagious to
start off with
a few floors down the hospital lab is
hunting for variants
staff are working around the clock
processing hundreds of coved pcr
tests each day it is very detailed very
detail-oriented
if you miss something if someone isn't
up to date
things will not get done their target a
missing gene that could be a red flag
for the uk variant
any sample that tests negative for the s
gene and positive for the other two
we forward to provincial lab for
sequencing of the uk strain
it is critical work the first step in a
sophisticated genomic surveillance
system
all suspicious samples are sent on to
another lab in the canadian covid19
genomics network
and nationwide alliance of government
and university labs
science studies serving the community dr
catalina lopez correa
is executive director i think we're now
a bit on
on a raise between the vaccine and the
virus
genomic sequencing mapping the entire
genetic code of the virus
is the only way to find the variance of
concern
about five percent of positive covari
tests in canada are being sequenced
so far they've detected cases of all
three highly contagious variants
in canada is that enough to get a sense
of how prevalent the variants are
in the population this is the one
million dollar question we have been
working with modelers
mathematicians statisticians to get to
the right number
we need to do more it will be important
to do more sequencing to really get a
detailed information on what's happening
with this virus
and not just in canada the virus is fast
in learning how to
treat our system we need to be fast
in learning how is the virus moving
and how is the virus evolving
there is no time to waste ontario is now
screening all
positive coveted tests for variants in
barrie ontario an outbreak raced through
this long-term care home
all 129 residents were infected and
70 have died the majority of the
infections are believed to be the uk
variant
dr terry snuch is with ubc's michael
smith laboratories
the more people that are infected the
more people that are going to be
hospitalized and unfortunately the more
people that will then die
the virus thrives when we move around it
needs human hosts to spread and mutate
yet there is no consensus among
countries about how to restrict travel
we're looking at really every measure
that's been
implemented by every country professor
kelly lee at bc's simon fraser
university
is part of an international group
analyzing travel restrictions
how do you think the
conversation the thinking the strategy
about
travel restrictions has evolved from the
beginning to where we are now
so at the beginning way back in january
february
the received wisdom really was that
travel related restrictions don't work
and who put out the recommendation that
countries should not adopt such measures
as this pandemic has unfolded
we've seen that actually there are some
situations where actually it can work
life in australia and new zealand is
largely back to normal
thanks to tight border controls and
strict lockdowns when even a single case
emerges
most of canada opted to flatten the
curve aiming to suppress
not eliminate the virus it's led to
thousands of deaths
and rounds of restrictions now with the
rise of the variants
there are calls for a new approach the
canadian shield strategy
is an effort to start thinking a bit
more strategically about where we're
going
what's the end game carolyn colan is an
infectious diseases modeler
at simon fraser university it would be
to get cases low
soon as soon as we can and then to
do the shield so that means support
reductions in transmission
by doing innovative things in rapid
testing by taking border measures to
stop introductions
we want to be reopening we want to be
getting people
back to what they need getting back to a
social life
professor lee believes canada's latest
restrictions including stopping flights
to the caribbean and mexico
are half measures the new variants that
what we know about them is they're
circulating globally
they're not where you think they are and
they're moving around you know much
faster than we can
actually detect them she wants tighter
controls including
on inter-provincial travel those new
variants didn't swim across the country
they didn't walk across the country they
moved with people
and so we have to really recognize that
that's one of the causes
and i think these new variants are
actually almost a new
outbreak we're like almost back to
january 2020 again
the virus is evolving in real time and
there is much uncertainty about the
impact on vaccines
and immunity the virus basically learn
how to play with your immune system and
start to evolve and transform and create
these mutations
to escape your immune system and that's
what
is really concerning
[Music]
in the anguish of manaus a father mourns
as his 19 year old daughter
is laid to rest there is a warning for
the world here
even when the worst seems to have passed
this virus can roar back
in new evolving forms this is a wake-up
call
to all of us that we will be dealing
as the virus uses its devices to evade
pressure particularly immunological
pressure
that we will continue to see the
evolution
of mutants
and the nurses are back on the river in
the race to deliver vaccines we need to
buy
time by maintaining or tightening public
health restrictions
otherwise the variants could outrun us
do you think the virus is still winning
at this point well it's quite quite an
intelligent virus i will say and it's
really um where we're seeing with these
three variants we spent
an entire year basically with no
variance of concern and in three months
we have already
three variants of concern that shows
that the virus is
basically learning and moving
coming up on the new reality think about
the stories that haven't been told
gentlemen right here together but why
did you and your brother feel the need
to start
the black academy we didn't want to uh
you know continuously be lost
in this perpetual loop of you know
canada not
uh recognizing and supporting you know
their black talent
[Music]
canada has long prided itself for its
film and television industry
success but for thousands of black
creatives in this country that success
largely
has not included them a lack of support
and opportunities in canada for
homegrown talent
has led to a deficit in black
representation both on and
off screen as kayla mclean tells us two
canadian brothers are stepping up to
fill that gap
creating opportunities for the next
generation of black talent
here at home
they've walked the oscars red carpet and
starred in hollywood blockbusters
actors and brothers shamir anderson and
stefan james are two of canada's
brightest talents
but before the two were featured in big
box office dramas
shamir and stefan were two kids with big
dreams and dedication
a quality their mother instilled in them
as they grew up in scarborough
in 2006 it was here at wexford
collegiate shamir's old high school
where he learned two
major things so how do you make out the
music teacher
the first about his love for acting the
second
that a journey in canada as a black
artist would be an isolating one
growing up i realized that there wasn't
a lot of examples
of black excellence on the national
stage and the school really showed me
that if you can work towards something
you can achieve it
wexford is known as a performing arts
school accepting some of the best talent
the greater toronto area has to offer
and merriam was the school's artistic
director at the time and recalls being
completely taken by shamir's talent
and drive shamir is actually relentless
he hears no he goes
what no what do i need to do to make it
happen this is a man who believes in
vision
a man who believes that anything is
possible
it was a trait the now 29 year old
passed on to his younger brother stefan
who during his youth could be seen in
the audience of shamir's plays
jamia was fierce like he was taking care
of stefan
from the get-go i know he drove him to
interviews
and to auditions i remember being you
know
13 14 years old and you know seeing
black people on stage seeing my brother
on stage just blew my mind you know it
made me believe that
it was possible that it was attainable
deputy marshall dolls
happy birthday soon after graduating in
2010 shamir ventured out into the acting
world
his younger brother safan following
close behind
their talent was quickly recognized
south of the border
hi look i need to talk to you about
something from a golden globe nominated
performance in homecoming to roles and
if beale street could talk
and selma twenty-seven-year-old stefan
has been taking the silver screen by
storm
shamir has earned impressive roles in
films like the destroyer opposite nicole
kidman
and in bruised halle berry's directorial
debut
but with all the success and accolades
garnered in the u.s
the siblings say they were left with an
unsettling feeling they couldn't shake
four or five years ago you know shamir
and i were seeing much of the same
problems that we see today
um you know in terms of just there being
a lack of support
and celebration and recognition of you
know black artists doing
incredible things not only in canada but
all over the world so making real
lasting change became the motivation for
the brothers next act
the black academy launched in december
2020 the black academy is a platform to
elevate foster
and showcase black canadian talent in
all areas
ranging from arts and culture to sports
and science
recently the brothers announced a
partnership with insight productions to
create canada's first
black focused award show celebrating
both anglophone and francophone talent
why did you and your brother feel the
need to start the black academy
we didn't want to you know continuously
be lost in this perpetual loop
of you know canada not uh recognizing
and supporting
you know their black talent i think that
you know drake's a big example of that
you know he almost had to get love uh
from some some
some guy in new orleans before you know
canada said he was cool
and uh and to us that's just not okay
there's not enough
governing bodies infrastructures places
to celebrate black excellence
i mean when black people slip and fall
we see that all over the news
it's very rare we get to hear the
pinball clemens of the world we're doing
incredible stuff
very little data exists on black
creators both behind and on the screen
in canada
but the stats that do exist paint a
troubling picture
racialized and black communities make up
about 22 percent of the population in
this country
but according to the black screen office
in the history of television
broadcasting
only five shows led by black creatives
have made it onto canadian television
think about the stories that haven't
been told
think about the people with the talent
that we haven't seen
because of this patriarchal society that
didn't see our humanity
that didn't believe that our stories
mattered jennifer holness is an
award-winning canadian writer and
producer
the 20-year veteran who now sits on the
black academy's board
says a long history of systemic racism
upheld by white industry gatekeepers
have shut out black and eating creatives
what does systemic racism look like
in the industry oh gosh i mean look
the entire industry is permeated with
systemic racism
from jump every place every part of it
we were told that if we wanted to get
more funding
we should make a canadian story that's
systemic because they're saying that
a black canadian with jamaican roots who
wants to tell a story
that develops a broader world that is
not a canadian story
please join me in honoring my little
brother
the lack of opportunity was painfully
evident for stefan at the canadian
screen awards in 2019
where he received the radius award an
honor given to a canadian who's making
waves globally
i was left with sort of a bittersweet
feeling after i left that stage thinking
man you know i may be you know one of a
handful
of black individuals that's that's gonna
be able to stand on this stage tonight
having an organization like the black
academy
support and nourish black talent
in canada heightens profile
creates avenues for more work and
creates a star system because this is
show business
and it's fed by stars
in the months following george floyd's
death with protests and renewed cries
for racial equality
raging around the world companies
including in canada were taking note
pledging their support on social media
to root out anti-black racism within
their industries
people were maybe paying attention for
the first time you know
maybe there was just nothing else to do
but they
finally hurt us looking back now uh
eight months later do you feel that
those promises are being kept or is it
all lip service
now here's the thing i actually think
that change takes time
so when i see the gatekeepers uh
changing
and when i see real money invested
then i will say unequivocally yeah it's
changed
according to shamir and stefan the much
needed financial backing for the black
academy
is still proving hard to get outside of
the canada media fund
no other organization has stepped up to
pledge their financial support
as for stefan investment in the black
academy means ensuring black canadian
boys and girls get to see what's
possible
and have opportunities and support to
chase their dreams
the same inspiration he got from
watching his brother
i can't tell you how many times you know
i've been on the streets of toronto and
somebody would be like oh my gosh we
played jesse owens like you're from here
it makes the idea
less of a of a crazy one when you're
able to see someone who comes from where
you come from
and be able to take it you know as far
as me and my brother have taken it
next week on the new reality this is a
humanitarian crisis that we're dealing
with lives are at risk right now
access to water is a basic human right
i'm an indigenous person
i have the right to basic human rights
it doesn't matter how many billions and
millions they spend
on indigenous projects the underlying
model remains
broken and they don't seem to want to
fix it enough is enough
i want to be able to turn on my
top and drink drink the water
[Music]
that is the new reality for this week
i'm donna friesen
thanks for joining us
you